hello I'm Martin Stanford welcome to our
tech review of 2013 we're going to start
with a successful year for the mobile
phone business phone still being
produced and purchased in massive
numbers samsung had a great year There s
for was a real popular phone sony came
back into the for with their said one
and HTC here with their one phone one
many an award by contrast blackberry
their new touch phone didn't really sell
in numbers and neither did the qwerty
keyboard variant so Apple we have to
report had another great year with two
new handsets the iphone 5s the posh one
and the more utilitarian 5c and they
added to that by releasing another new
variant of the iPad the ultra-thin
ultralight ipad air the ipad has always
been about a premium piece of hardware
and integrated software and they're
sticking to that so these products are
being offered at the same price they
were last year the previous generation
is still around or slightly cheaper if
that's what you want but I think
fundamentally you know Apple strategy is
the same as it was which is just keep
making good stuff and and iterate very
slowly which is frustrating for the
press but you know maybe good for
consumers what I find fascinating is
that there doesn't seem to be any
breakout sort of Wow gadget sort of
gizmodo moment in there which is sort of
the sense of it's got a fingerprint
scanner I can demo demo to my mates or
whatever I think when people do get it
and I'll take it home that we keen to
show it off to their friends with them
they'll be not sure which bit they're
supposed to show off 2013 was a
fantastic year for the games industry
not one but two new consoles came out
not only Microsoft's Xbox one but of
course Sony's ps4 as it happened within
days of each other but for the games
publishers to new iterations of
Assassin's Creed another storyline for
call of duty and for grand theft auto 5
the biggest launch for the new release
of a game any time in history so we've
come into the gaming we were in Las
Vegas for june's III gaming conference
now this is something else that's
getting a lot of attention here at e3
it's a game called rain from an
independent producer and what's getting
the attention for gamers and non-gamers
alike is the quality of the picture they
talk about the graphic fidelity and it
the picture quality of this game is
quite extraordinary also it's got a real
strong storyline it's and the narrative
is there it's certainly not a
first-person shooter game and it again
demonstrates that that broadening of
games and their appeal the fact that
this is something you could be watching
on your TV is entertainment watching as
a movie it's a game here and all of
those things are coming together and the
console war was reignited as Microsoft
pitched the xbox one up against the
PlayStation 4 in November we assembled a
group of reviewers to put the new
consoles through their paces really I
think the key piece of technology for
the differentiates the Xbox one is the
kinect sensor technology in there is set
up for the future it's there's some
really advanced stuff such as quite
scary kind of like skin palpitations to
sense your heartbeat and also reading
your emotions and I think that as
someone who speaks regularly to games
developers I think the game developers
can do really interesting things with
that like read your emotion and then
maybe adapt the game to how well you're
reacting to certain characters the ps3
has gone through about three different
renditions of how it looks and how it
feels from the contour point of view if
you look at the controller just as a
starting point it's so much better than
the DualShock 3 i've never been a plan
of the jaw chuck 3 and to hold the
DualShock 4 it's so much easier and more
comfortable to play the games they've
had a new features like a touchpad on
the top of the controller so that's
going to be interesting as to how they
use that like any year 2013 has seen its
fair share of ups and downs in the world
of technology so here's our round-up of
the people and the products on the way
up or on the slide down over the last 12
months it would Snowden the NSA
whistleblower dominated the news in 2013
by leaking details of a complex
surveillance program involving British
and American intelligence agencies Sam
called his actions heroic but the boss
of mi6 certainly did not agree
the leaks from Snowden have been very
damaging they put our operations at risk
is clear that our adversaries are
rubbing their hands with glee al Qaeda
is lapping it up Google's executive
chairman Eric Schmidt was a popular
search in 2013 in January he
controversially traveled to North Korea
never the summer was forced to defend
his company's tax arrangements the tech
giant has been accused of avoiding tax
on the millions of pounds that it makes
in the UK but mr. Schmidt said it wasn't
his company's fault it is normal for
companies to do what Google is doing
British companies do the same thing in
America this is in fact how the
international tax regime works I would
be very happy to have a more rational
structure and as I said we would
continue to invest to to honor to serve
the citizens of Britain and I would
further say to you that our investment
here is without qualification one person
that certainly did enjoy some highs this
year commander Chris Hadfield the
Canadian astronaut gained a cult
following with his antics on board the
International Space Station he produced
breath taking photographs of the earth
tweeted them from space and even had
time to record a music video
the most peculiar
when I recorded it the the genius of
Bowie was evident in that it affected
the place affected how I sang the song
and i loved how just the vocal sounded
it surprised me and that then led to my
friends putting some instrumentals
underneath and then with permission from
Bowie to videotape it on board and then
my son and an editor to put together the
final product over at Yahoo their CEO
Marissa Mayer made a few changes the
former Google executive band employees
working from home and led a campaign to
try and entice a younger audience in
create a list of favorite topic one of
the people to benefit from this was a 17
year old Nick dollar seal from London
yahoo paid a reported 18 million pounds
for his news app summly it uses an
algorithm to create bite-sized summaries
of news stories and even had backing
from Stephen Fry we caught up with Nick
back in March after rising for my
history exams I realized that Google and
being these search engines are quite
inefficient you have all of these
results but how do you decide what you
want to press on and so I thought that
summaries of previews would help you
decide so I coded it and it took about
two or three months and I got a
prototype out there in July of 2011 in
the investors context about a month
later 2013 was a great year for
television technology here's an o LED
screen brighter better black brighter
whites than ever before and that was
eclipsed in part by the rise and rise of
4k TV or ultra high-definition that's
four times better than your HD picture
and perhaps the biggest event of all
involved Twitter they went public in
November valued at a whopping 24 point
nine billion dollars despite having no
assets and no profit things didn't go
smoothly for facebook when they hand out
chairs the year before so the lack of
drama was almost a disappointment
well that's it for this year make sure
you keep up to date with all the tech
stories on the scan use for iPad app and
on our website sky news com we'll see
you in the new year